-How are you, Michael?
-Great.
Thanks for having me.
-Thank you so much
for being here.
So I was fascinated
by the contents of this book,
but also,
just what goes into covering
stories like these?
The Comey firing,
the Mueller investigation.
You met sources at airports
late at night.
You had to chase them down
in D.C.
It must've been
quite an undertaking.
-I mean, covering a Trump
story was like another --
like nothing we had
ever covered before,
primarily because of the speed.
It was just so fast
and the news cycles
turned over so quickly.
And we went to great lengths,
as you were saying.
I lay out in the book
about getting up
at 3:00 in the morning
and driving to airports
to pick people up
that were flying in,
who I wanted to talk to,
thinking that was the only time
I would get a chance
to actually speak with them.
And to stay competitive
and in this story,
we pushed ourselves
in ways that I think
we never thought
we'd be tested in.
-You have a brilliant
piece of wording
in describing what it's like
to interview Donald Trump,
which is you say it's like
"unzipping fog,"
[ Laughing ]
which will stay with me
a long time.
You did manage to sit down
and interview him
at Mar-a-Lago,
but it wasn't really scheduled.
How did it come about?
-So, what I was able to do
was I was able to have one
of the president's friends
take me to lunch at his club
and the friend basically said,
"When the president comes
off the course,
we'll go over and talk to him
and maybe you
can interview him."
So, we did this.
I was there.
I looked like I was wearing
golf clothes.
And we went over
and the president greeted me
and I crouched down next
to him like a catcher
because I wanted
his undivided attention
and I knew,
if I was just standing there
at the table with other people,
then I wouldn't get a chance
to talk to him
and I needed to sort of
convince him
that he would sit with me
for an interview.
So I crouched like a catcher
and I sat there
as long as I could
and he was going on and on
about state and local
taxes and stuff.
And I said, "Mr. President" --
My legs were killing me
and I said, "Mr. President,
this is all really interesting.
Why don't we sit down
and do an interview?"
And he said, "Okay,
let me just finish lunch,"
which I describe as him
eating a head of lettuce
that looked like it
had been dowsed
in Thousand Island dressing.
-[ Laughing ]
-So I go back to my seat and,
within a matter of moments,
I hear, "Michael, Michael,
get over here!"
And I had a chance to sit
and interview
the president
for a half an hour.
-It's really amazing,
the energy he has for talking
when he's had his lettuce.
[ Laughter ]
You draw attention to --
you know, I think people
who follow the story
have heard the name Don McGahn,
but maybe don't know him as well
as they, say,
know a Comey or Mueller.
You describe him as one
of the most fascinating
people of this story.
Can you talk about how you
came to that conclusion,
insofar as the role
Don McGahn has played
in the Trump administration?
-So, McGahn, to me,
is consequential
for so many reasons.
First of all, he was in charge
of the umbilical cord,
the tie between Trump and his
base, which is the judges,
the thing that allowed
conservatives
to stay with the president
when he behaved in ways
that they found to be unsavory.
Because of that and because
of the impact McGahn had,
we will be living
in Don McGahn's America
for decades and decades to come,
because of how he remade
the federal judiciary.
He was also a chief
container of Trump,
someone who was stopping
the president
from hurting himself
and the country
and the office
of the presidency.
And, on top of that, he was
a witness against the president
in an existential threat
to the presidency,
being the Mueller investigation.
So McGahn, as a lawyer,
was being used as a witness
against his client.
Now, the question you probably
may have is like,
"Why would McGahn stay,
if this was all going on?"
He stayed because he had
a never and again opportunity
to remake the courts and was
willing to endure all of this
and the risks of it, in order
to get the courts remade.
-There is this idea
that you talk about
and, obviously, others
have talked about, you know,
especially when we talk
about why did people stay,
which is the idea
of adults in the room.
Do you feel like this
theory, in the end,
turned out to be a bad one,
that they were not particularly
good adults in the room,
or was it just a reminder
that some adults
cannot control their children?
-I think that there were
more adults earlier
in the administration
and they had more success.
That does not mean that they
had complete success
or should be absolved
for anything that happened
in the first few years
of the administration.
But the John Kellys
of the world, the Don McGahns,
were more of a barrier
around the president.
The president effectively
got rid of people like that
and has less barriers
in his way now.
And I think that has left
the president
even more emboldened
than ever before
and he has a very unusual
use of power
and interest in using power
and there are those fewer
guardrails now around him.
-Well, Michael, I'm so impressed
that you wrote this book
[ Laughing ]
while you continue
to be a working reporter.
I do not know how
you juggle them both,
but I am happy on each count
and thank you so much
for being with us tonight.
-Thanks so much for having me.